how does a movie producer view a
screenplay versus how an actor filmmaker
or writer views the screenplay I think
well I mean since I'm not an actor or
you know some of these other people I
can't I can't as I speak to their
process but I mean I think a producer
probably is a lot more comprehensive in
terms of when I look at a script I'm
thinking about a lot of different being
about all those things it's specifically
how how they relate budget wise and
fiscally but also you know how that hmm
you know the creative and the fiscal
will work together so you know I when I
read the script I'm thinking about story
and I'm thinking about the arc of the
characters and I'm thinking about if
conflict I'm thinking about why are we
telling this story but I'm also thinking
okay who would I get to play these okay
I get to play these roles on this budget
level like what are some decent names
who am i picturing in this you know I'm
thinking about and if I mean I'm
presuming in this situation that the
movies real that's not just a script I'm
not just reading it for fun but it's
like okay we're making this picture like
this pictures funded mark read the
script so I'm reading and I'm like okay
how we gonna pull off that we need that
this kind of grandiose house or there's
a good example would be there's a
project I'm working on right now called
li2 and very hopeful oh we'll shoot this
summer the financing is getting locked
down as we speak and a very cool
thriller about these sort of two and
combine helicopter parents these sort of
like wealthy parents they've got these
two ten year old twins and the twins are
they're kind of like they're the parents
are find them hard to tutor and at the
point the boys got like a learning
disability and the girls kind of too
smart for her own good too rebellious
and they're having trouble tutoring
these kids in it and the kids have their
own language that they speak in when
they don't want the parents to know what
they're saying so the parents buy this
device called Ali - it's kinda like a an
Alexa or a Google home device like many
smart devices you know it connects to
the house it can lock the door can open
the windows it can do all these kind of
turned the lights down answer questions
whatever and it starts at first the kids
don't like it but then it starts
learning their language and it befriends
them and then it and then the kids start
and it starts you know that they start
it starts tutoring you know the kids
better than the parents can and
eventually the kids start pushing back
on the parents a little bit it starts
overstepping its bounds and the parents
are finally like we need to get rid of
this thing
at first it's good but then it starts to
take take it a little bit over the line
and by this point the kids like love
this thing so much that they secretly
get another one without the parents
knowing and it remembers them like his
mind is in the cloud like it remembers
these two kids and the parents decide
we're gonna send the kids to two
different private schools instead of
together and the kids are like freaking
out because they don't want other twins
they don't wanna be separated so the ly2
starts planning with the kids to take
out the parents it starts plotting with
them to get rid of the parents and it
controls the house and it locks the door
you can you know so this whole big it
built to this really big climax and it's
just a really really well-written script
so I'm using that as an example because
when I'm reading the script and it looks
like you know this is moving toward
production I'm looking at this I'm going
okay this house is such a major location
we need to be able to it's like a
character they'll lead to the voice of
the lead to what does it look like the
lights on it it glows or whatever is
that gonna be a practical effect is that
gonna be a post visual effect how are we
gonna pull that off the casting so
you've got the two parents you've also
got the kids when are we gonna shoot
this thing because with kids you can
only shoot so many hours so with their
age group maybe you get nine hours a day
with them if it's during a school year
you can always shoot for say six of
those hours and the other three they're
having to be schooled
yeah the set teacher has to be schooling
them but if it's in the summer when
school is not in as long as the set
teachers on set we don't have to burn
shooting time with schooling so okay you
know summer is probably a better time to
shoot it so I'm giving you some examples
but you know production design in the
house I'm looking at some of these
things and I'm saying you know okay we
need this and we need we need to dress
the kids room like this okay you know
there's a very specific style do I know
somebody who might be able to execute
that style it's very postmodern I've
worked with a production designer that
did this and Wow sound is such a big
deal you know some thinking about all
these all of these things as I'm reading
it as opposed to and actors reading it
yes they're considering story I think
everybody with some sort of creative
you know position is thinking about
story to some degree but actor is gonna
be much more focused on their role in
the arc of their role and the Scimitar
is gonna be much more focused they're
gonna be reading and seeing something
totally different they're gonna say oh
wow okay so you got a bunch of exterior
night out here by the pool are we gonna
light the pool how we kind of light up
gonna light the water how we gonna
they're gonna be looking at it that way
I see you got the shot that follows them
through the house and so they're gonna
want to talk to the director about how
that I'm thinking about all that stuff
that I'm thinking about like okay dude
we're gonna have the budget for those
kind of lights and creatively if we
can't pull something off how are we
gonna be able to you know to make that
we can't pull that off with the budget
or where there's some other logistical
circumstance that's gonna make that
unreasonable what are we gonna have to
change in the script to do that and I'm
also a line producer at upm so I am I'm
breaking down the script I am thinking
about all of these things okay we need
Steadicam to pull that off and we need
it so I really do get down to that level
of detail but it to some degree but I
I'm thinking about everything you know
in one form or fashion as it rates to
creative and fiscal and how those two
things work together and I think I think
probably a lot of other I think writers
are probably focused more on story and
not a lot of not necessarily on the
logistics so when I talk to them I'm
like but how are we gonna pull this off
you know yeah oh yeah well so from a
producer producers perspective we're
talking were thinking more about
execution well I think a lot of writers
just they just tell the story they want
to tell and they don't necessarily think
about how it will be done which is fine
you're the writer that's your job just
get the story out but when it starts to
become real and then we have to start
approaching how we're gonna do it
sometimes some things for logistical
reasons have to have to shift do you
think a lot of new writers don't see
that just yet like you really have to
once someone's been in the game for a
while they can really scale things back
to one room one town you know I find the
people that the writers that grasp it
the quickest are - it's who have also
produced or who have been involved in
something other than I mean a lot of
times you know writers they like locking
themselves in a way in a room and just
working by themselves they haven't
necessary been part of the collaborative
creative process but the ones who have
the ones who have also director also
produced and understand the exigencies
of production I think those people have
a better grasp when I say
this is gonna be tough to do here are
some ways we might be able to do it you
know as an example I just recently
budgeted a script called not long
together I think is fantastic and there
was a scene in it you know one bigger
scene where the guy shows up and it's a
big woman has died and there's ambulance
and cop cars and there's a helicopter
with a spotlight because they're looking
in the water and things and he's like
yeah we'll probably have to get rid of
that money well so there might be a
couple ways that we can do this if we
have a decent enough I said you know a
couple cop cars I know what it cost to
rent I know what ambulances cost to rent
you know things like 350 a day for
picture vehicles some caution tape and a
few background actors walking through
making it look busy I said your biggest
issues your helicopter but we might be
able to get like a scissor lift and you
know 5k or something and do the
spotlight and then license the stock
footage shot of a 4k stock footage shot
of a police helicopter and just cut to
you know him and they're like yeah I'm
like because a stock footage shot you
could license that for a hundred fifty
bucks
go on get images and you know what we
did and we're like well look at all
these great 4k helicopter shots and you
cut that in and you can get your
helicopter I mean you can have a few cop
cars in a few ambulances and you know
whatever and it probably cost us this
much you know maybe we can do it for you
know whatever thousand how much you know
however many thousand dollars and they
were like no yeah actually so coming up
with say creative solutions sometimes
it's changes to the script or sometimes
it's like it might not be how you're
thinking but here's another way we can
do it that's an example and he was like
yeah oh this is awesome okay great done
you